started call me in Vegas and I wanted to
do stand up so bad I just didn't know
how to get in I would call every Comedy
Club every week at least twice a week
right because you know this back in the
day no internet so I would just call and
the only guy that would pick up was the
comedy club at the Riviera and I would
call him and he was like hey hey what's
what's going on and I was like hey I'm a
comic I'm local I'm like 18. it's like
I'd love to just open the show man I got
some uh some stuff I think you'd like I
don't have anything I don't even know
what to say on the phone he goes do you
have a tape I go I don't have a tape but
I know I'd kill it man I'm really funny
it's like Hey look call me back when you
got a tape and I would do it every week
and I would try and change my voice and
then one time I started out it's a true
story and then one time he goes hey kid
I know it's you
he goes look you need tape stop calling
me Steve sharepa get the [ __ ] out of
here it's Sopranos Steve trip yeah did
you ever get up there never got up